L  21sNTURY JIM CROW G CONTROVEA
BUILDINGSHT  ITS OWNISITOLOLIC
FIICAN LAWMAKERS IN US PASA BIL
T POPULATEWHNEE OFTHOSFLUENTTHIT
JACKSON AS A WHOLE I83BLACK. TH
THE STAT MADA FEW VEJACK
KEY CHANGES TO THE HOUSE BILL.
HOW ARE REACTING T
THOSCHANOTING WITH SOM AN LEARS
JA VIOLENCE HAS
SPIKED IN .
HEY WERE
VOICING CONCERNS ABOUT THIBILL.
FROM FIRST
INTRODUCED ON THE HOUS TO
WHE W ONSIDE IS, RATHER G A TRID
EXPANDED JURY DICTIOOF
DE.YOST POLICE, THAT
S LEADERS, WHICH AR, INSTEAD O
N  THAT IS
THEREIN LIF THE MAJO
THISDICTION OF THE
CE
WIDEEAN
AGREEMENT TH THE JACKSON
POLICE FORCEO LIE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OVER THE ALOEL
POLIFFND WHY
OD
>> IT'E TO TAL
WEE ADDRESSED OLPROBLEMS.
FUNDING  GM IS NOTRTMENT AS A SM
WORKING.
E AT
THIS LEGISLATURE HASNTRODUL EXP
THE ENTI
THAT TERRIFIES ME ANAN ME.
>> Repor TS LO
AROUND THIS.LOOK NHER THAN T-SHT
'VT  "JACKSON VFESUS EVERYBODY,
PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL, CLUDIN
KEEP JACKSON SAFER AND INCREASE
TO KEEP UP WITTH'VE HAD TO DEAL.
OPPONENTS SAY THERE ARE BETTER
WAYS TO ADDRESS CONCERNS THAN
.
R JIMENEZ,SO MUC
LET'KS SO.
MUCH FOR JOINING US.STATE SENAT
YOD TO APARTHEID.
BUT THE STATES
OVER OTHER PARTS OJASO
U TH TE Y
STATE SENATE?
>> WHEN I THINK ABOUT THISILOFGY
ON
LEER
WED THE STATE DS CIT MANS.
SU
BALLISTIC T CLOSESETHPPORT AL S
MATYT ES AFERENCORD OF JACKSON'
TT ERRYING TO THIE PE T
TEMPORAR AND BRING
REURD OTHE
OF INTN TO THE TFO R ONE OE BI
SPONSORS, TREY
CL THEIMONY OF ADDE LO COURTS.HR
MacARTHUR JUSTICE , RUE DATA
COMPARIS OF THE BACKLOGSARISONRN
ACES, FELT THAT TO B
APPON ELEC
ELL, WE SIMPLY WANT
THAT FEEO E NOTION O
INTE T  LK CITY ENOUGPR NO
CRNA THE
LAMAR, VERSIONTHE SON.EN WHITE
WAS THENSTANCE?
E ARE NO STA
WITHIN THAT DISTRICT.
THAT HAS BEELLY
AR AUMIONSORDER TO DISENFRANCHI
POTI
I  AND I AGREE'TTHMO OF TH JACK
ER PEOE IN021, HUGM
N, RATHER THING THAN NOTHING AN
EY'RE NOT GOING UNIND PROVIDE ST
TA THATIL N THIS?HE
SOLUTIONS.NU
S WHY WEY
T D THE INSTUTHA
I TOLD Y, S OUR
JO IN WITHNK AND NATIONAL LEAGU
ADDITIONALBRINGING I
H EXPERTS F THLEWE SR COMMUNITYA
WHETHER THERE N'N
NTERS TO HOLLER DOES
SPECIA WITH THAT POPULATION SO
THACH,PO
YOUN, THAT THEY DON'NT SOLIOR .
SPORTS THA O P